it was always going to be a day like no
other a royal event to heal the fishes
of the past and to let the new take its
place in comfort with the old
[Music]
[Applause]
but it was the intimacy and not the
grandeur that won the day from the start
Prince William smiled set the tone it
was going to be a great wedding as well
[Music]
[Applause]
the bride was indeed truly radiant as
her father a man already known to
William as simply Mike led her through
the Abbey to meet her prince
and at the altar the first winning
moment you look lovely
you look beautiful from the groom
[Music]
followed by an impish smirk from best
man Harry and then the whispered jerk
this was supposed to be a small family
affair
[Music]
it could have been buckle berry village
church after all
right down to that sudden moment of loss
written across a mother's face dearly
beloved we are gathered here in the
sight of God and in the face of this
congregation to join together this man
and this woman in holy matrimony which
is an honorable estate instituted of God
himself signifying unto us the mystical
union that is betwixt Christ and His
Church to the Dean of Westminster the
welcome to the Archbishop of Canterbury
the marriage William Arthur Philip Louis
will turn out have this woman to thy
wedded wife to live together according
to God's law in the holiest state of
matrimony
with our love her comfort her honor and
keep her in sickness and in health and
forsaking all other keep thee only unto
her so long as ye both shall live
Katherine Elizabeth wilt thou have this
man to thy wedded husband to live
together according to God's law in the
holiest state of matrimony once I love
him comfort him honor and keep him in
sickness and in health and forsaking all
other keep thee only unto him so long as
ye both shall live i William Arthur
Phillip Louie I William Arthur Philip
Louie take thee Catherine Elizabeth
Catherine Elizabeth tonight waited life
it's my wedded wife to have and to hold
from this day forward to happen to hold
from this day forward for better for
worse for better for worse for richer
for poorer for richer for poorer in
sickness and in health in sickness and
in health to love and to cherish
to love and to cherish till death us do
part to death osteopath according to
God's holy law according to God's holy
law and thereto I give thee my truth and
that's who I give thee in my trophy
I Katherine Elizabeth take the William
Arthur Philip Louie
to my wedded husband to have and to hold
from this day forward for better for
worse for richer for poorer in sickness
and in health to love and to cherish
till death us do part according to God's
holy law what are you - that's how you
do and thereto I give thee my truth the
ring of Welsh gold was reluctant at
first only slightly landing snugly in
the end on the finger of the Duchess of
Cambridge destined to one day become
queen with this ring I thee Wed with my
body I the honour with my body I the
honour and all my worldly goods with the
iShare and all my worldly goods with the
usher in the name of her father in the
name of the Father and of the son of the
Son and of the Holy Ghost and of the
Holy Ghost amen I pronounce that they be
man and wife together in the name of the
Father and of the Son and of the Holy
Ghost amen
[Music]
amongst the indigenous Englishness of
hornbeam and field maple Hubert Perry's
Jerusalem
[Music]
a true country wedding boiled down to
the splendor of this ancient Abbey
[Music]
a wedding shared as we know by billions
across the globe and just outside
[Music]
this is the first royal wedding where
friends and family outnumbered the
official guests
and the first to complete over eight
years of courtship like most of us
William and Kate set their own pace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you happy she asked
[Music]
[Applause]
the connection with the crowds never
faltered
people love that William rides a
motorbike and played football in
Battersea Park three days ago
and that the Duchess of Cambridge has
parents who work for a living
[Applause]
for the first time in over 300 years a
future monarch has looked outside the
inner circle for his bride and brought
her home
and then the move to the palace
followed by the crowd
[Applause]
and the balcony a planned event but for
both bride and people below it was
another winning moment
[Applause]
followed by another
[Applause]
and another still
before the old and new joined again in
the traditional fly past
[Music]
Lancaster hurricane and Spitfire
[Music]
two tornadoes and two typhoons
[Applause]
all too soon it was over time for one
last glance but the last surprise was
left to the future king and his bride an
open-top self-drive out of the palace
overlooked by his buddies from the air
sea rescue
a romance sealed forever simultaneously
rekindling a monarchy's love affair with
its people
Andrew Wilson Sky News
[Music]
[Applause]